in the waters around sri lanka you'll
find the world's only stilt fishermen
perched atop a handmade stilt driven
into the sand
these fishermen are some of the last of
their kind but for those who still fish
it is about carrying on a tradition only
found in this part of the world Muhammad
Ali Siddiq lemon ma ma ma Llewellyn ad
Department permitted the history of
stilt fishing is said to go back to
World War two when food shortages and a
lack of proper boats caused fishermen to
get creative for their catch fishing
from a stick off shore help them catch
more fish Maulana data by the kite
I was a fairy of nature P al banna
Maccabean evolved an updating manual
only tuxedo editor
you know it wanted this what about Sofia
in the life in
Marlene has Nibbana kilo a la Papa
[Music]
fishing isn't as lucrative as it once
was
so most stilt fishermen have other jobs
to pay the bills but continue to stilt
fish to keep the tradition alive
negative or amber on my wall of the
epitaph la patate after Lucy agency him
up inaudible do you got a name on behind
me enough salmon caliber is our name a
cappella our he's already unknown image
if I'm know we had an active agent I'm
I'm a I study staff diadem Callaghan yet
you